a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono pani j
oggi andiamo avanti con penombra black
flag eravamo rimasti la settimana scorsa
che praticamente avevo battuto il
vermone che stava nell'altra stanza che
ho giustamente chiusa con un barile che
peserà sì e no un chilo per un verme di
250 tonnellate ma vabbè vabbè adesso non
so che cosa si può fare
c'era il computer che non ho capito che
cosa serviva sbloccato qualcosa che non
so neanche che cosa va beh io direi di
uscire a questo punto non ha dimenticato
niente vero tipo di cassetti ok
bene allora devo tornare nella stanza di
prima qua c'è a parte la cia gentile non
c'è nient'altro a meno che non ci sia
niente altro cupi dietro ok sono un
vandalo ok va beh direi di proseguire
allora abbiamo sbloccato una valvola che
non ideali che valvola sia non lo so
forse tipo indietro ok ok perfetto non
me la ricordavo raga è passata una
settimana non mi ricordo più neanche
come si gioca
e perfetto sbloccato qualcosa non so
cosa secondo me ho il presentimento che
debba seguire il tubo quindi vado a
vedere che cosa effettivamente sono
riuscito a sbloccare anche se non ho
idea di che cosa sia ok e così te ne va
in giro con un pezzo di corpo varo nel
tuo zainetto e poi io sono quello
cattivo quale pezzo di corpo umano che
cazzo dici ma in effetti in effetti c'è
anche ragione comunque va bene vediamo
di seguire i tubi raga non idea di dove
mi portino molto probabilmente finirò
tipo nel laboratorio di dexter
però se non li seguo non so dove andare
allora probabilmente deve utilizzare la
maschera antigas no e non c'è più allora
la parola buongiorno non c'era lei prima
qui
senta amica le mestruazioni di quel
poveretto del tuo amico scimmia sta bene
non mi pare abbia una bella cera no
guardi neanche lei è una bella cera
sinceramente senta non vorrei sembrarle
troppo di liscio però io ho trovato una
mano è per caso su come funzionerà la
mangi c'è un po di attack no c'è la sega
solo una domanda sola per caso visto
piffer in giro no ok io me ne vado
grazie mille molto socievole molto
simpatico e vediamo di andare da qualche
parte anche se non so precisamente dove
lo scanner non mi riconoscerai uno
scanner aretina
ok sto pensando di fare una cosa della
quale mi pentirò amaramente però la devo
fare senta mi scusi io non so se devo
fare così spero vivamente di no però nel
caso mi perdoni ok non devo fare così
fortunatamente è per chi non l'ha capito
che cosa volessi fare è meglio che non
lo dica proseguiamo allora devo andare
da qualche parte ho sbloccato non so
cosa
ok ok forse forse ho capito devo provare
ad andare di qua
c'era una un'altra porta bloccata
ma che cazzo
ho riempito la siringa con la sostanza
contenuta la provetta ok va bene che
cosa mi serve sta roba
mi sono visto drogando ma perché oddio
c'è ma dai ma che sta succedendo
ok va bene raga el abbiamo capito
alla fine la soluzione era praticamente
drogarsi perché tanto il protagonista di
penombra è un drogato e dobbiamo farcene
una ragione
effettivamente non so che cosa vi può
servire a parte gli scherzi che cazzo mi
sono iniettato c'è non lo so ok la palla
luce diventata verde
ok perfetto questa è già una cosa buona
vabbè praticamente mi sono drogato e la
porta si è aperta
io ma perché non tanto evito di fare
domande che non servono a niente niente
ok appunto bene allora sono entrato qui
dentro cosa devo fare qui dentro non lo
so
beh c'è una leva noi tiriamo anche se
non so che cazzo serve salve
ok prende in prestito la testa ok oddio
che figo no no no che figata sud alla
testa allungabile o cazzo bene mi stava
accadendo
ho preso una testa raga adesso posso
evidentemente fare lo scanner retinico
anche se era una cosa un po più diciamo
macabra avrei preferito tagliare la
testa del tipo di prima però va bene
anche così vasta che riesco ad andare
avanti che un'ora che sono bloccati in
sto punto vi devo fare qualcosa no devo
tornare indietro di nuovo allo scanner
retinico ragazzi sto mettendo un secolo
perché veramente penombra
questo per un brand è un po più
enigmatico di quello di prima però se
non altro c'è chi ha meno pif ci fa
divertire tutti quanti compreso me e
allora devo riuscire a tornare al punto
di prima se riesco ad esso ma l'apporto
dello scanner retinico credo magari mi
sto confondendo io no veramente la lega
c'è ma che cazzo succede scomparendo le
vie c'è prima acqua c'era lo zio che
cazzo succede mi sono drogato pesante
ricomparsa la porta
vedi chiave sempre stata qui senti non è
colpa mia se mi metto dosi di cocaina
pesante cioè è colpa del protagonista e
non faccio niente
vabbè io ho piccola testa scostamento
perfetto
che vuoi o perfetto sono convinto che
non mancherà poco alla meta perfetto mi
sembra di essere entrato in un santuario
di residenti vol
sono quasi sicuro che dov'ero prima io
non ci debba più tornare e sono anche
contento di questo di batterie sta messo
abbastanza bene ok perfetto salviamo
facciamoci un altra volta di droga come
se non bastasse
e vabbè devo fare qualcosa qui dentro
per forza c'è uno strano meccanismo che
blocca la porta deve se deve pur esserci
un modo per aprirla
te lo dico io a pedate la pro c'è sta
roba qui che non so che cos'è ma non ho
idea non vorrei che fosse tipo il
laboratorio di dexter appunto che ti
dice un libro e si apre la porta
però però non penso allora ecco infatti
lo sapevo lo sapevo
effettivamente era come adesso non sono
un elaborato o buongiorno evidentemente
dexter è rimasto intrappolato troppo
tempo e a lui non posso segali la destra
vero no ok ma vabbè io vado sega la
testa tutti quanti perché tanto prima o
poi succederà allora c'è qualcosa qui
dentro c'è una lampada perfetto c'è una
lettera conclusioni di virtus
ok è come al solito raga se volete
leggere fate voi allora c'è un bottone
premiamo noi premiamo qualsiasi cosa
tanto peggio di così non è che può
andare
penso di aver aperto la porta spero la
porta di prima
ok ci siamo raga stiamo andando avanti a
caso tanto non so neanche che cosa sto
facendo
precisamente non sono anche dove sto
andando perché ok c'è una caverna le
caverne in penombra non mi piacciono dei
bruttissimi ricordi
ok noi facciamo finta di niente
proseguiamo si cazzi ma chi cazzo è
questo mi ricorda veramente residenti
voce non lo so allora è un vecchio tubo
di cemento forse serviva per le fogne
non lo so ma qui ci arrivo lì sopra mi
serve una scala enorme cos'è c'è una ed
evo che cos'è sta roba una grossa tavola
di legno qua sta tremando tutto è la
tavola di legno non so che cosa mi serve
però ok perfetto va e maledizione devo
portare devono portare sti cosi
probabilmente perché se non riesco a
salire ok ci sono ragazzi ci sono
perfetto devo tirare giu ok
devo tirare giù la la leva anche se non
so che cosa serve perfetto
ebbene ci siamo allora non so dove sto
andando non ne ho la più pallida idea
non mi fate domande non fatevene neanche
voi perché tanto inutile
l'unica cosa che so è che questa è la
strada giusta mi si è spenta la torcia
perché si è scaricata la torcia tanto
ciò talmente tante batterie che la dura
c'è mi fa una pippa
devo andare di sopra si perfetto allora
come faccio devo improvvisarmi ezio
auditore o cosa
si no madonna che salvataggio ea ci sono
le travi perfetto c'erano le travi
ragazzi mi vado a complicare la vita
come al solito e presumo che io devo
ammette ma se mi cade una trave come
cazzo faccio no ecco perfetto no non è
difficile se sai che cosa devi fare
almeno allora vai qua maledizione
ok piano piano ok perfetto ci siamo ci
siamo se ci sono o cazzo cazzo
buongiorno non l'ho messo io barile e
c'era già prima
buongiorno senta io qui ho una sega non
so che cosa mi serve
devo devo salire la scala mi scusi se
l'è pesto la testa però devo salire
allora dice qualcosa non mi interessa
devo prenderla con la roba di che cazzo
è strano artefatto ne ho già due dischi
cosi non so che cosa mi servono raga
bevo bevo c'è una porta lì cosa devo
fare
meno male che quel masso non mi è caduto
addosso ok ficacci un calcio fa qualcosa
devo spin ok perfetto merda ok
vai con gli atti di vandalismo puro ci
siamo ragazzi amo arrivati lì sopra c'è
soli tornate lascio su quell si sono
picchiati addosso ma la nello show
normale
c'è un computer che mi spiegate a che
cosa è collegato come al solito c'è la
vela tipa che vuole fare webcam e mi
metto a posto sto bene sì sì perfetto
allora vai già bella sei venuto credo
davvero non pensavo si perdesse in
disturbo il mio partner in laboratorio
ok perfetto mai fatto finire di leggere
ma sono io qui il tuo partner ha cercato
di usarmi che senso hanno fatto in tempo
a leggere dovrei fare una piccola
deviazioni superficie ok lasciamo che è
meglio ma siamo fuori
sono uscito ragazzo è uscito non ci
credo sono uscito oggi sono fuori io non
entro più forte lievi non entro più non
so bene cosa potrebbe salimi questo
spray ma per ora lotterò ok c'è
materiale scuro appiccicosa nella botte
sto morendo di freddo ma non me ne frega
niente
preferisco morire di freddo che è che
andare lì dentro è completamente
ghiacciato che perfetto vai con lo spray
la levano lo scoutman si scalderà così
ok allora una sega no
bengala e perfetto buttato un bengala
posso provare a tirarci addosso un
detersivo
evidentemente no forse un qualcosa di un
po più pesante
ok ragazze un'altra via perfetto dovevo
uscire di qua allora c'è un'altra
baracca che i vantaggi è crollato
qualcosa è crollato e merda se fossi in
te in parte lo so lo senti smettila di
parlare sei un idiota mi dai fastidio
ci sono le tra merda merda merda merda
ok bene non sono cadute fortunatamente
perché magari mi servivano c'è una
scatola di scarpe della foot locker va
bene
noi entriamo qui dentro ci sarà qualcosa
sicuro un accendino lo zippo e scarico
veramente si dice accendino non sapevo
si dicesse anche zippo si può non è una
marca di accendini più che altro vabbè
lasciamo perdere
c'è qualcosa qui sotto non c'è una
scatola e l'appunto ciò la butta la
butto giù maledetta
ok spero di non beccare un pinguino in
testa sono capace di farlo secondo me
devo muovermi e crow la merda è crollato
il ponte mi servono le travi e devo
anche darmi una cazzo di mossa perché
sto morendo di freddo perfetto è un
problema questo non ce la faccio a
passare come faccio
devo provare a dar fuoco a sta roba così
mi riscaldo perfetto
ok raga è una situazione un po precaria
questa come faccio a tornare indietro
tipo non devo buttare l'europa oppure
salto ma non penso di riuscire ad
arrivarci a meno che io non salti ho
capito forse la scatola di sotto non
dovevo buttarla giù
e vabbè tanto c'è tanta roba spero di
riuscire ad arrivarci devo costruire
tipo un ponte una specie di torre per
per buttarmici sopra però se mi cade la
roba joe è un po un problema ok ok
fermatelo feroce raga
è scommesso cazzo sono morto è un
problema questo laga perché ho buttato
giù la scatola come faccio
spero che ci sia di nuovo che perfetto
la rifacciamo devo devo aiutare il sud e
la roba
ok ci sappiano piano piano ma che cazzo
fai vai piano
no se ok no no cazzo ok ok madonna mi
sentiro né qui di priest a ragazzo sarà
anche se non sa neanche se
effettivamente devo fare così lo spero
veramente perché sennò sono perso calma
e sangue freddo è impossibile fare sto
pezzo non ci devo provare vai se se
ma non serve la trave io ci vado di
salto se ce l'ho fatta
devo riuscire ad arrivare all'altro
punto prima di morire ghiacciato e anzi
congelato il mio italiano fa veramente
ribrezzo perfetto ci sono devo
scongelare l'affare poi ci dovrei essere
allora tiriamo giù l'accendino la fiamma
era civile troppo da brevi serve
qualcosa di più potente allora vai con
lo spray è ok no effettivamente devo
combinarli così vediamo credo di poterlo
usare con un piccolo lanciafiamme
perfetto ho usato anche un
antidolorifico a caso perfetto ma è ok
il lanciafiamme sinceramente mi
servirebbe anche contro pil
se devo dirla tutta sarebbe fantastico
però vabbè andiamo avanti lo stesso
spendono aspettiamo che arrivi di se ne
frega questo renda tappezzato il tutto
cervello veramente rendere un deficiente
di merda che ha fatto la sua fine vi
terrò stretto questo pezzo di stoffa
potrebbe servirmi certo aggrappati pure
un pezzo di stoffa come se fosse la tua
ultima speranza
io me ne vado di qua perché veramente
non so più che cosa fare
c'è qualcosa di meno perfetto c'è una
porta che devo rientrare dentro raga
devo rientrare dentro io veramente non
so più che cosa pensare
cos'è sta roba
e botta è riempita di benzina devo
riuscire a dargli fuoco sta roba
penso che le sposatevi deciderà se
rimango così vicino quando lo brucio
allora facciamo tipo effetto molotov
proviamo a metterci il panno l'iper
fetto ma ok perfetto ci siamo mai
lanciafiamme la stoffa prenderà fuoco ad
viggiù parla con qualcosa di
infiammabile che ne so io l'alcol
vai veloce che sto morendo ok
vai merda sto morendo non sento più le
mani non resistere a lungo che ci sono
ci sono varie mamma mia che vandalo
ragazzi sta puntata sono stato un
bandalo assurdo ho buttato giù qualsiasi
cosa ma ci scommetto quello che volete
che siamo arrivati nel punto più
difficile diciamo più pauroso o che
l'ato lista di cose da fare non mi
interessa è uscito fammi il favore stai
zitto
beh c'è una vetrata fantastico raga non
sto dove sto andando devono trovare
soltanto un punto di salvataggio perché
voglio chiuderla qui in centro ragazzi
di pali dentro ne sono quasi sicuro
questo possa enorme mi fa piacere c'è la
tipa lì dentro laga devo aprire quella
porta
enorme veramente un cazzo ok ciao pif
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo mi fece la sedia
mettiti nella sedia siediti fra qualcosa
pif aiuto aiuto scazzi devo entrare da
qualche parte si sposta madonna non mi
aspettavo questa è bruttissimo rifiuta
piffero uscito o perfetto c'è una porta
chiudi chiudi chiudi tv di chiodi chiude
ok ti odia merda ok ho chiuso merda
cazzo no no no no no no no no no no no
no no ti prego ti prego ti prego allora
prima porta a cazzo
è ok aiuterai aiuta ragazze video da
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e trovate
sempre in descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi 10.001
prossimo vitobello ragazzi